praise and crime taking a huge toll on
America's Most Progressive City Whole
Foods shutting down its Flagship
location in downtown San Francisco this
just one year after opening the store
that's had a concern for the safety of
their workers the store plagued by
rampant drug use thieves looting all the
shopping baskets sadly it comes as no
shock San Francisco spiraling out of out
of control uh you know judge I think
that one of the things we're talking
generational today it seems one of the
things that's changed is that the old
social contract has been broken now you
would never see Brazen thieves in
previous years where it's Shameless
going in uh 5 10 15 of them roughing up
innocent store Keepers but stealing
stuff in a way I mean there was always
shoplifting and this and that but the
the fact that they just reject the rules
utterly of civilization and you know I
think the the the operative word was
shame and it's shameful they have no
shame they have no dignity they have no
shame they're not worried about it they
there's a sense of entitlement that work
ethic that we had in a generation before
or whatever one you want to attribute to
is gone I'm entitled and you got to pay
me it's the life of Julia during the
Obama years you know the government
comes in and takes care of you but look
in terms of this particular segment I've
been saying for years that law
enforcement determines the success of a
particular area if you've got crime
running rampant whether it's in in the
90s when I was a D.A in the 2000s when I
was a D.A then it is impossible for you
to maintain a business or the value of
your home forget about the safety of
your children and that's where we are
right now and most people were
like-minded most people believed that we
did but everything is upside down it's
like this evil is spreading across the
country and it's it's like this you know
social justice this boat Warriors you
know the bottom line is people are being
shot stabbed beaten brutalized thieves
are taking whatever they want and
nobody's doing anything about it and
that's why this store the Whole Foods in
San Francisco is closing if they were
too stupid to figure that out and they
opened a year ago we'll shame on them
and they even sold the baskets by the
way they still in the baskets from the
store so all in all what we've got is a
society where there are no consequences
you can thank the Democrats for it I
don't care what anybody says it's in the
big Democrat cities in San Francisco you
know they they've got you know open-air
drug markets and they fornicate and they
defecate and they do everything in front
of our kids I'm sorry you know the
different the difference is uh caught on
tape also uh like the Bob Lee the uh the
App Guy yep he's he's dying he's dead on
his feet and you watch him and then you
watch them finally uh ultimately
collapse I mean mean my God how can this
be where we are at now the San Francisco
voters don't care Heraldo they can
control their own destiny they vote for
this garbage election after election
after election well they did throw out
the D.A so what they still have the
stupid Board of Supervisors who wants to
fund reparations instead of the police
and the media is broken too the media
doesn't even ask Gavin Newsom right the
the flagship Whole Food store has shut
down in San Francisco and said they
asked him about some city in Florida
I mean what about Nancy no one asks
Nancy her own cities falling apart and
no one asks her about that they ask
about Trump
this city is disgusting but the voters
will control New York City no we're
talking about San Francisco and now they
can't have organic rhubarb they cannot
have fair trade coconuts and that's what
they wanted and now they can't have it I
don't feel bad for them what they can't
have Dana is fentanyl and I think that
that has changed worsened aggravated
everything well Jesse brings up Newsome
and that's what I was going to say that
so he was the mayor there and he's the
governor now and from a legal I would
even imagine if you're the governor and
you watch the one of the jewels of
America going into a death spiral and
you go to Mississippi to campaign for
your Democratic governor yeah that's
weird are you sitting in Florida and you
clap your hands like this while your
city is deteriorating you have
businesses like Whole Foods that say we
moved in here a year ago imagine what
sort of incentives they were given by
the city like please come we need you
and they decide probably against their
better judgment they went ahead and did
it and now you have that business
leaving how many jobs does that take
with them and so now you'll have a
continuation of the problem but where
really is where is Gavin Newsom why
isn't there a takeover of San Francisco
why why isn't is that something that he
it may come today well at what point
after all the businesses leave and all
the taxpayers leave and then you have
the city that we all used to love that
is now just a terrible place where all
the Kates are happening yeah but in that
regard Greg you have uh one of the worst
aspects is you have the kids destroying
the services the the their moms and dads
now are the ones deprived they're the
ones who have to uh you know exert extra
time and energy and money uh to do the
the necessaries I look at Minneapolis I
mean it's just once or Baltimore we
covered with Freddie gray uh in 2015. uh
it the cities are losing
their their their Essence and and we're
watching it happen there's a big
difference with San Francisco because
Whole Foods isn't in a bad neighborhood
it's on it's on Market Street that's
their Main Street
um the the cash App Guy what was this
that was a nice that was Pelosi's
district and remember her own husband
was stabbed or beaten in her house I
mean she knows crime and she knows this
intimately right and it's still it's as
though
it doesn't resonate but this is not like
Chicago where all the crime is
concentrated in one area in its case
it's all over San Francisco so so why is
Nancy Pelosi not saying I have no idea I
have no idea all I know is it's the
fault of the city the city's politicians
I think it's a fall to the media who
look at uh this kind of crime as a local
issue somebody's watching this right now
it's like what do I care about San
Francisco why do I care about that and
so but you know what is a national story
The reparation story or trans but crime
isn't like if you talk other producers
at other networks have said as much that
crime is a local story so you don't hear
about it and suddenly it explodes when
we were talking about it for years and
nobody else talked about it then there
are the insurance companies that are
basically telling you just stay out of
it you know just let these people rip
you off so I think the solution is much
almost what you said Geraldo in the
previous thing you got to let these
cities die so they can be reborn because
right now the people of the lunatics
running the Asylum haven't exhausted
their lunacy and the people the elites
they're Fortress they're four just
briefly one of the London Bridge says
the problem they can't find cops they
can't get cops
she defunded them 120 million dollars
she cut and they're being trashed anyway
hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now